[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el pasado
fin de semana chile eligió en unos macro
comicios a los 155 convencionales que
redactarán una nueva carta magna del
país la derecha fue la gran derrotada de
la izquierda y los independientes
lograron más de dos tercios de las
sillas hoy hablaremos con alondra
carrillo vidal elegida constituyente que
se presentó como candidata independiente
gracias por estar aquí y alondra como
recibe su elección para ser parte de
esta constituyente y cuáles son las
principales propuestas con las que
avanzará en la redacción de esta nueva
carta magna la recibimos con alegría y
con entusiasmo porque nuestra elección
conforma parte de la elección en general
de candidaturas de los movimientos
sociales con carácter independiente que
venimos a hacer oposición a todos los
partidos que han administrado la
precarización de la vida a lo largo de
estos años nuestra principal voluntad es
materializar la decisión que ya tomaron
los pueblos de chile de poner fin al
neoliberalismo en nuestro país y
consagrar un estado solidario garante de
derecho plurinacional
desde el feminismo ahora como interpreta
los resultados de los comicios hay un
hastío de la clase gobernante en el país
por supuesto que hay un gesto hacia los
sectores que han gobernado no sé si le
llamaría un hastío y yo creo que lo que
hay es lo mismo que se expresó en la
revuelta se trata de un balance
histórico de los pueblos que habitan
nuestro país y ese balance es un balance
de décadas de administración neoliberal
que han precarizado crecientemente la
vida de amplias capas de la población y
que han destruido de manera creciente
también las condiciones naturales de
nuestra existencia en el país no a
través del extractivismo yo pienso que
es la confianza en nuestras propias
fuerzas la que quedó demostrada hace
unos días y también la confianza en que
podemos abrir un momento histórico
radicalmente nuevo a través de la acción
política auto organizada de los pueblos
a lo hondo a veces la primera vez que
una constituyente tiene participación
paritaria y se escribirá con enfoque de
género en la práctica qué efectos tienen
estas condiciones bueno éste también no
solamente la primera constitución no
constituyente paritaria del mundo
también la primera que se da en el seno
de un ciclo de movilizaciones mundiales
feministas y esto muestra que la
variedad en otro momento histórico
podría haberse considerado un mínimo
democrático en este caso fue un techo
para la participación de mujeres muchas
de las cuales de micheli y feminista
muchas de las cuales tuvieron que ceder
sus cupos dentro de la convención a
varones de su lista porque los varones
estaban sus representados no es todo lo
que va a significar respecto de la
presencia de mujeres no lo sabemos aún
pero sí sabemos que el feminismo el que
ha abierto este camino y que este
feminismo desborda las claves incluso
con las que se pensó este proceso que en
un inicio se había evaluado que tenía un
carácter histórico pero que hoy vemos
que está también poniendo algunos
límites a una condición histórica
inédita respecto de la potencia del
feminismo
cree que una nueva carta magna es la
solución a los problemas que enfrenta
chile por supuesto que no el cambio de
la constitución es la solución pero es
un momento necesario para poder impulsar
un proceso de transformación global de
la vida en chile y que pueda modificar
las condiciones institucionales para
llevar adelante un programa de
transformación global que pueda
conseguir lo que mencionábamos antes no
en este estado solidario garante de
derechos y plurinacional que pueda poner
la vida humana y extra humana en el
centro y por sobre las ganancias de unos
pocos que han sido lo que ha gobernado
la vida en nuestro país durante 30 años
no es la solución es un momento de un
proceso histórico de transformación que
vamos a llevar adelante
por último alondra que se debió la
abstención de las votaciones el fin de
semana fue únicamente por kobe 19 uno o
más razones de fondo pienso que no
solamente fue el covent aunque sin
embargo es una razón muy poderosa cierto
para para dar cuenta de la extensión
pero también hubo una desinformación muy
grande no
y fue el estado el que el que incumplió
su responsabilidad política de informar
a la población y más encima escribimos
ante una elección que reunía estas
elecciones extraordinarias de candidatas
y candidatos a la convención
constitucional con elecciones regulares
del estado como la renovación de las
alcaldías de la concejalía y además se
elegía un cargo que por primera vez
eligen democráticamente que es la
gobernación regional reunir a estas
cuatro elecciones en un mismo momento
sin informar adecuadamente a la
ciudadanía respecto de qué era lo que se
estaba votando en cada uno de los casos
y sin estar a la altura del momento
histórico extraordinario que estábamos
viviendo sin duda que mermó abiertamente
la participación y haya una
responsabilidad directa del estado
alondras gracias por su tiempo y por
estar con nosotros en france 24 sale
otra carrillo constituyente chilena
hasta aquí 5 minutos con hasta una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]